amikor elolvastam ezeket a beszámolókat
akkor éreztem hogy ez egy nagyon jó
beszélgetés lesz ugyanis itt van
mélyebben valami amit meg szeretnék
érteni és kíváncsi vagyok íy hogy mi
lesz erre a válaszod úgy ahogy le is
írtad ebbe a beszámolóba hogy nem a
kolináris élvezetek hajtottak oda és és
nem is turistaként mentél oda sőt olyan
helyeken jártatok ahova még a helyiek se
mennek teljesen érintetlen területekre
és nem is a békák hajtottak oda nem a
nem a nem azért mentél oda hogy hogy
békákat néz hanem valami mélyebben
mintogyha bennem ez fogalmazódott meg de
majd kijavíthatsz hogy lássam hogy jól
értem-e hogy miért mentél oda hogy
találkozz a
határaiddal találkozz az emberiség
határaival mert valójában amikor annyira
kimész a természetbe ahogy mondtad gps
nélkül egy öngyilkosság odamenni
és ennyire látni ezt a vad szépségét a
természetnek és eltá odni mindentől a
családtól is ha kell azért hogy azért
hogy ezt a határt megizzleld és utána
persze visszagyere de de mégis ebben van
egy egy egy
fontos fontos belső út te hogyan
fogalmaznád meg miért mentél oda hát ez
ez a jó kérdés amin egész végig rágódtam
mg mentem arrafelé ültem a repülőn 14
órán volt arra hogy gondolkozzak hogy
tényleg őszintén minek mert ugye
én régebb sokat utazgattam úgyhogy azért
láttam elég sok mindent úgyhogy annyira
nem jövök izgalomba ettől építészetileg
ecuador nem egy nagy kaland kulinárisan
mint volt rá szól szintén nem egy nagy
kaland
és akkor felmerül a kérdés hogy miért de
azt hiszem hogy ez volt a ez a végső
válasz az egészre hogy hogy egy kicsit
megpróbáljam magamat hogy valóban
ennyire betokosodtam a hétköznapi
rutinomba valóban
ennyire kisvárosi emberré váltam aki aki
már nem akar kimozdulni már minden pont
jól van úgy ahogy van valóban elértem
azt a kort ahol az ember lezárja ügyesen
körbe az ajtócskákat egyen keresztül
járkál ki a nagyvilágba s azzal annyi és
és hogy ezt ezt szerettem volna igazából
megpróbálni ugyanakkor meg nyilván
a maga a természet az az tényleg
borzasztóan látványos borzasztóan
látványos micsoda kifejezés tehát hogy
hogy nagyon látványos az az azt hiszem a
borzasztó szónak is helye van mert ahogy
leírtad ez egy egyszerre gyilkos és
egyszerre gyönyörű igen igen igen igen
igen tehát a meredek hegyoldalak az egy
idő után rutinná válik de az első
igazi ilyen hegymászós tehát ah ahol
tényleg meredeken kellett fölmenni azért
nagyon nézegettem hogy hűha ennek nem
lesz jó vége persze kialakul visszatérve
hogy h miért a a választ a mai napig nem
tudom megfogalmazni de hogy hogy ez volt
az alapgondolat hogy hogy akkor egy
kicsit
kicsit belepiszkálják abba a hamuba ami
ott a tűzhelyben van hogy alatta még
van-e valami parázs valami még mozog-e
bennem hálistennek úgy érzem hogy igen
tehát hogy
még hogy hogy még nem akarom lezárni az
életemet nem akar
teljessé teljesként elfogadni hogy akkor
oké eddig volt ez így szépen körbe van
minden falazva hanem tovább tovább még
több hülyeséggel kell foglalkozni mert
ez frissen tart mert mert hogyha ha ha
megállunk és és elfogadunk merev
korlátokat akkor akkor nagyon gyorsan
megvénülünk nyilván ez nem azt jelenti
hogy mindenki akkor vadabbnál vadabb
helyekre kell el menni ezt a egyszerű
hétköznapokban nagyon jól lehet követ
udvarhely meg pláné tehát hogy hogy itt
van van amit látni csak ugye nézni kell
tehát gyakorlatilag azt mondod hogy
mindenki a saját kontextusában meg tudja
kapni azt ami pont a határát súrolja egy
picit túlmegy azon amit éppen
lehetségesnek tart
pontosan hány hete jöttél
haza ez assiszem az ötödik hét igen ez
az ötödik hét assiszem milyen volt
hazatérni hát ez nagyon furcsa nagyon
furcsa érzés még az előző gondolathoz
valamit hozzá szeretnék fűzni hogy
amikor ugye egy hirtelen felindulásb van
lefoglaltam a repülőjegyet meg ottan
ment az egyezkedés akkor arra gondoltam
ugyanez a kérdés minek tényleg őszintén
már nem vagyok annyira ifjonti hévvel
teli hősöcske hogy akkor most nekivágok
hanem minek hogyha megfogunk egy
eekvadorit áthozzuk udvarhelyre és
udvarhelyről megfogunk egy udvarhelyt és
átviszük ecvadorra ba és ottan másfél
hónapot él az egyik és a másik és
elkerülhetetlen hogy előbb-utóbb rutinná
válik neki az a környezet ahol van az a
kérdés hogy ezen a rutinon fölül van-e
valami van-e valami amit tud ajánlani
udvarhely vagy akkor ugye ebben az
esetben ecuador én ezt keresem és tudom
hogy udvarhely a rutinon fölül tud adni
nagyon sokat tehát egy egy egy olyan
vasárnapi séta
amikor ami mikor nem nagyon járnak az
autók mikor szépen süt a nap vagy mikor
szépek a felhők az egy hatalmas
felüdülés ebben a városbaan
úgyhogy ne ne siessünk erről a témáról
el egy másik témáról mert ez egy pont ez
az amiről akartam beszélgetni hogy mi az
amit hoztál ecuadorból ahogy másképp
látod udvarhelyet ez például egy dolog
amit megfogalmaztál hogy végigolvasva
ezt a a naplót azt láttam hogy a ez egy
áldás amit nem veszünk észre a nap mind
nap áldás hogy nem nedves gumicsizmába
kell menjünk és és az hogy hogy létezik
olyan hogy napsütés és létezik olyan
hogy hatalmas felhőket látunk az égen és
gyönyörű napsütés mellett tudunk sétálni
és a a környezetünk nem akar megölni
minden pillanatban
persze vannak itt is vadab környékek de
eekuadorban így ahogy elolvastam ez ez
tényleg egy hihetetlen biodiver
vélyekkel rendelkező hely lehetett